and as we saw in our banking report in
China the QR color code on a smartphone
can restrict your movements green means
you're healthy and you can go about
daily life but yellow or red mean you
present a risk we met a human rights
lawyer who says the software is being
used as a form of State Control
lawyer Wang Yu hasn't been able to move
around freely for some time
as a Critic of the regime she's often
been under house arrest but now the
government has developed a new
restriction on movement the corona
warning app is compulsory Nationwide but
no longer works for her Wang you can't
even go shopping when she needs to go to
court for a sensitive case the app shows
a yellow code even after multiple
negative PCR tests
foreign
but they turned my code to Yellow I
couldn't do anything you can hardly move
you can't go anywhere
is incensed that there are no laws
covering the operation of the corona
Health app
there's no paperwork no regulations
nothing so the restrictions imposed
through the app are totally legal
getting around the city is now an
obstacle course even in the taxi the
health apps QR code has to be scanned
luckily the driver only needs one
passenger to log in
what if someone doesn't scan it
you have to that's the rule
but what if they don't have a cell phone
then they can't go by taxi
a green code on the health app is also
required for buses and subways
even access to Apartments is now
monitored
everyone in Beijing lives within a gated
compound with only one entrance there
are checkpoints everywhere
Wang Yu lives in the Beijing suburbs
only after a heated argument do the
security guards allow her into her own
Building without a scan
all visitors must also log in
no one knows what will happen tomorrow
maybe the guard won't let me through and
I won't be able to get in and this is
all illegal yeah
the Chinese government has turned the
corona app into a surveillance tool
every time it's scanned names and
locations are passed on to the police